ask and you shall receive folders are
coming to the playstation 5 plus sony is
partnering with backbone for a new
mobile controller and more on today's
gamespot news
after gamespot.com's op-ed on the
playstation 5 needing folders especially
now thanks to the new playstation plus
extra and premium services mere days
later sony announced the next beta
update for the system will implement
just that coincidence i think not while
it's awesome that this feature is coming
to the ps5 that is a catch rather than
existing in the home screen's row of
games what sony is dubbing as game lists
will reside within the systems game
library found at the end of the row
although as this is currently in beta
there's a chance this could change for
the system updates wide release each
game list can contain up to 100 titles
and up to 15 game lists can be created
game lists can contain disks digital or
cloud-based titles and the game can be
included in more than one game list
additional beta features that begin
rolling out today to select users are
1440p support in case you're playing on
a computer monitor of that resolution
you will no longer be locked to the
lower res 1080p experience as well as
the ability to compare the system's 3d
audio to a regular stereo setup head to
the gamespot link in the description for
the full details and keep an eye out for
an email from sony in case you were
selected for this beta test sticking
with playstation news the popular mobile
backbone controller is getting a ps5
makeover while the device isn't getting
dual sense features such as haptic
feedback and adapter triggers it is
getting a matching white overhaul as
well as translucent buttons and d-pad
meaning if you're using the device for
playstation remote play you'll actually
have face buttons that match the
on-screen input prompts the device is
available starting today for the same
price as the normal backbone however it
does not include three months of game
pass ultimate for new subscribers that
the regular controller does
according to backbone's website the
playstation edition will still include
three months of discord nitro a month of
apple arcade and two months of stadium
pro all for new subscribers from
playstation to nintendo the company has
finally announced the next wave of mario
kart 8 deluxe tracks coming on august
4th including a brand new track not seen
in a previous mario kart title wave 2
will also bring some fan favorites to
the game the turnip cup is composed of
new york minute from mario kart tour
mario circuit 3 from super mario kart
calamari desert from mario kart 64 and
waluigi pinball from mario kart ds the
propeller cup will include sydney sprint
from mario kart tour snowland from mario
kart super circuit mushroom gorge from
mario kart wii and the brand new course
sky high sunday which will also come to
mario kart's tour at a later date to get
these courses you can either spend 25
for all six eventual waves which
nintendo plans to release by the end of
2023 or subscribe to the expansion pass
for nintendo switch online from nintendo
to xbox the console's august games with
gold include community sim calico action
platformer scourge bringer the open
world third person shooter saints row 2
and the stealth action title monaco if
you don't also have a ps5 and have
missed out on stray perhaps calico can
give you your cat fix and now is the
perfect time to check out saints row 2
ahead of the series reboot later in
august more details including when these
games drop on xbox live gold in the link
in the description below and that is it
for today's gamespot news are you
planning on picking up a backbone
playstation edition let us know in the
comments below and we'll see you here
tomorrow on gamespot